[Musica]
Benvenuti alla mia festa alla quale
nessuno ha voluto partecipare ma forse
da un certo punto di vista è meglio così
odio stare insieme a determinate persone
perché ogni volta che voglio raccontare
di una serie italiana che sto guardando
la domanda di tutti è sempre la stessa
Karim perché hai visto mandalorian No ma
ho visto guida astrologica per cuori
infranti entrambe le stagioni sono una
curiosità di che segno mi hai detto che
sei non te l'ho mai detto e sto
recuperando letteralmente qualsiasi cosa
mi si pari davanti tra Mediaset e Rai
Netflix prime Vi è mai capitato quel
blocco dalla vera e troppa scelta quando
apri il catalogo Netflix e ti si parla
davanti migliaia e migliaia di scelte
possibili Ma tu non ne scegli neanche
una dicendo non ho niente da guardare
Ecco spostarsi andare su Rai e Mediaset
e come avere altri due armadi pieni di
roba da mettersi e dopo tutta sta roba
italiana che guardo la mia testa diventa
una macchina da aneddoti
tu lo sapevi che Jerry Calà è stato
ricoverato in ospedale a causa di un
infarto e prima che i medici lo
operassero gli chiedevano mi dice il
libidine dice faccio una libidine così
cominciamo a operare Ecco Questi sono
gli aneddoti che io dico ad un gruppo di
persone quando si presentano Ed è
proprio per questo che ci troviamo qui
oggi lo sapevi che c'è una leggenda che
narra le gesta di questo produttore
italiano che tanti anni fa prende un
aereo vola in America riesce a stare due
mesi sul set di Friends e decide sai
cosa voglio farlo in Italia un po' più
economico e con un titolo che ha valore
di marketing Zero via Zanardi 33 è una
sitcom del 2001 andata in onda su Italia
1 che prende tantissimo ispirazione da
Friends appunto che poi Google la
indicizza se tu lo cerchi la trova
subito le trovo subito informazioni Ma
pensa a comprare una maglia con scritto
via Zana è una via di Bologna perché è
ambientata a Bologna via Zanardi 33 fan
official Italia prima di parlare delle
singole puntate però vorrei analizzare
l'intera serie e la prima cosa che ho
trovato e tu ci scherzavi è proprio la
fanpage su Facebook con 48 like e tra
l'altro ho fatto vari post a distanza di
anni e l'ultimo è del 2022 Ma oltre i
fan ci sono anche Purtroppo molti
detrattori ricordo che questa serie era
stata lanciata con un certo battage
pubblicitario ma ben presto venne
ricollocata in seconda serata a causa
cattivi ascolti obiettivamente era per
lunghi tratti inguardabile poco
originale e a vederla oggi quasi
vent'anni dopo è pure invecchiata
maluccio Tra l'altro non so voi ma io
adoro leggere i commenti di qualcosa
vecchissimo prima di andarmela a
recuperare Perché voglio farmi un'idea
vent'anni dopo di quello che realmente
Pensa alla gente ma questa merda doveva
essere la soprattutto italiana Friends a
posto C'è un vecchio posto in un forum
dove viene
bombardata di insulti da tutti quelli
che hanno commentato certo non aiuta che
il form si chiamasse Central Park un
pochino di parte ma a parte questo ci
sono articoli di quel periodo che ne
parlavano molto bene definendola una
serie non buonista e non politicamente
corretta dove addirittura C'erano anche
sesso e parolacce in Mediaset follia
quindi c'è questa divisione tra chi la
mediamente odiata a parte i 48 like
della pagina fanpage e gli articoli che
ne elogiavano le lodi ma secondo me ci
sono un paio di cose che non sono da
sottovalutare quel famoso produttore
televisivo che si è fatto il viaggio di
due mesi non è altri che Rosario Rinaldo
un produttore con tantissimi anni di
esperienza sulle spalle che ha fondato
l'acrosproduction a voi questo nome
probabilmente non vi dirà niente ma è la
casa di produzione che ha fatto Tra le
tante cose scam e Prisma e tra i due
registi di via Zanardi 33 c'è Antonello
De Leo regista Tra le altre cose del
cortometraggio senza parole candidato
agli Oscar Mica bau bau micio micio
Cosa ridi lo sapevi che questa serie
definita non politicamente corretta
aveva la sigla fatta dai Lunapop tra
l'altro con una canzone fatta apposta
originale per la serie chiamata donne in
perizoma Ovviamente non poteva chiamarsi
nessun altro modo lo sentite il non
politica li correct
per questa serie era avanguardia Cioè
sta serie era avanti di 20 anni per dire
in una può farlo Ho fatto un album solo
che si chiama squarez tu sai cosa vuol
dire squarez nel loro gruppo Square
c'era la parola per definire la merda
cavi avanguardia Ma facciamo una
piccolissima presentazione barra
comparazione dei protagonisti abbiamo
Dino a Brescia che sarebbe il rosso
italiano Enrico silvestrin che è
praticamente Chandler e non ci volevo
credere Elio Germano che la controparte
circa di Joy Enrico silvestrin Dino a
Brescia fermarlo nella stessa sitcom
Queste sono proprio i motivi per cui io
guardo queste cose Proprio questi e
guarda come ti collego scam con via
Zanardi 33 Elio Germano Federico Cesari
C'è Alessandra Bertin che è la nostra
Fibi Ginevra colonna barra Monica e
Antonia liskova che più o meno fa Rachel
e di cosa parla questa prima puntata per
attirare più gente possibile
di niente di nulla perché è una puntata
quasi di transizione solo per più o meno
presentarti i personaggi La cosa più
interessante che mi ricordo sono i SET
che ti arrivano in faccia dicendo Guarda
siamo anche noi capaci di farli come
quelli americani e non sono così male
alla fine l'hai Light di questo episodio
è Enrico silvestrin che non trovo la
tessera della mensa quindi non può
mangiare Mi sa che l'ho scordato a casa
Questo è il primo episodio verso la fine
c'è il classico Montalcino musicale con
un giorno migliore dei Lunapop
[Musica]
e poi si conclude dura 25 minuti quindi
5 minuti in più delle sitcom normali di
quel periodo che di solito erano intorno
ai 20 ma io sentendo serie non buonista
nel 2001 ero lì per le cose più
trasgressioni ma in questo primo
episodio non c'è tantissimo Ci sono solo
loro che in modo un po' denigratorio
insultano una ragazza brutta la donna
più brutta del mondo dice che per
battezzare hanno chiamato L'esorcista
e dopo averla finita ho preso la
decisione di guardarle tutte queste
benedette puntate tutte 24 e per tutto
il tempo guardandola mi sono chiesto Ma
qualcuno l'ha vista stasera ai tempi se
la ricorda perché sono sicuro che
qualcuno dicendo via Zanardi 33 gli si è
risvegliato qualcosa nel cervello ma a
tutti quelli che ho chiesto nessuno
aveva la minima idea di cosa fosse
l'unica cosa che è successa dal 2001 a
oggi e che in Lunapop hanno fatto una
remastered di donne in perizoma che si
può trovare su Spotify quella Vespa
donne in perizoma bravi tutti quindi
parto con la seconda ma Volevo
raccontarvi una minuzia che mi ha fatto
molto ridere essendo media sette io le
puntate Le sto guardando su Infinity sul
sito la sinossi della seconda puntata è
I ragazzi tirano a sorte per chi deve
pulire il water intasato da tre mesi
toccherà Stefano e non è vero quella è
la sinossi dei primi due minuti della
puntata poi non si parla più di questa
cosa qua e questo mi ha fatto molto
ridere perché anche L'addetto che doveva
guardare la puntata e scrivere l'asino
Sì su Infinity non l'ha fatto ha
guardato proprio i primi due tre minuti
ha visto cosa succedeva e l'ha scritto
il punto più alto di questa puntata è
quando parlando tra di loro si scopre
che Elio Germano ha come un invisibile
Aura di sfigaggine e paragonano questo
alone di sfiga alla Lone Viola che c'era
intorno alle persone protagoniste della
pubblicità contro l'AIDS di quel periodo
è come se intorno li si creasse questo
al Ecco di
sfigate dell'AIDS quella cosa Viola
quella ma non ne parliamo e diciamo
soltanto che la prima gestare di questa
serie e Cesare Cremonini quando aveva
ancora le punte dei capelli rossi
i colpi di sole rossi bellissimo E come
ogni buona sitcom che si rispetti è
pieno di camei Cesare Cremonini I pali e
dispari Dario Vergassola Lillo e Greg ma
dopo aver visto anche il terzo episodio
Infinity mi fa partire il settimo e mi
accorgo che le puntate caricate e
visibili sono solo una manciata tipo una
decina neanche e ho detto Eccolo qua ci
siamo bloccati però con una piccola
ricerca scopro che via Zanardi 33 c'è
anche su timvision ma anche lì non ci
sono tutte le puntate no ce n'è una sola
e manco la prima la numero 3 che cazzo
perché Ma grazie a Dio qualche buon
samaritano ha caricato tutte le puntate
prese da videocassette di via Zanardi 33
su YouTube e le ha messe in ordine
cronologico in una playlist Peccato che
anche lì sia un macello le puntate 3-4
in realtà sono la serie e La7 a volte ce
n'è mezza della puntata prima e mezza
della puntata dopo è un macello senza
pari e ho dovuto guardarlo in queste
condizioni nelle puntate successive il
meccanismo del politica li correct
inizia a prendere forma abbiamo battute
sui grassi gente sovrappeso che sfonda
le cyclette vendute da Roncato sono
grassa grassa come una balena vera
Jovanotti
come una foca
un professore anziano che ci prova con
una studentessa molto molto giovane E
ciliegina sulla torta loro a un certo
punto vanno in un ospedale e beccano
Barbara D'Urso
è un crossover tra via Zanardi e la
dottoressa Giò Questo è il motivo per
cui la vita è bella e poi arriva la mia
puntata preferita ti scopre che il
personaggio di Dino a Brescia è
omosessuale Tra l'altro sempre per la
categoria aneddoti italiani io Dino a
Brescia l'ho scoperto per la prima volta
nel film Cado dalle nubi di Checco
Zalone in cui fa il cugino omosessuale
Quindi io due volte ho visto Dino a
Brescia e due volte ha fatto un
personaggio omosessuale e tra l'altro in
via Zanardi 33 arriva da Monopoli
come me e ad un certo punto arriva il
mio episodio preferito c'è questa scena
in stazione dove lui sta aspettando la
sua metà sembra che stia per arrivare
una ragazza in realtà la ragazza lo
supera e lui accoglie un altro ragazzo
il problema è che gli autori essendo una
sitcom ci hanno messo le risate in
sottofondo
io sono contento che in quel periodo lì
abbiano affrontato l'omosessualità ma
guardandolo adesso noti che l'hanno
affrontata nel modo più banale possibile
cioè gli amici maschi sono tutti un po'
in dubbio e un pochino repulsi da questa
cosa qua ti piace uscire con gli uomini
no Eh sì Non solo ci esco ma ci faccio
Ti prego
mentre le amiche femmine sono quelle più
capito
[Musica]
sono molto più aperte accettano tutto
quanto non c'è nulla di cui vergognarsi
eccetera eccetera Tu mi vuoi dire che
tra Pamela Anderson e Gigi Marzullo
trovi più attraente Gigi marzullon
questo anche quando nella stessa puntata
parlano di Revenge porn Le ragazze sono
contrarie i ragazzi a volte dicono che è
necessario A me sembra che mandare in
rete le immagini della propria ex sia
veramente di cattivo gusto per lei ma
anche per te
con le mie signore prestazione
diventerai sicuramente un mito No Pensa
che pubblicità che sarebbe osteria
Quanto bisogna contestualizzarla questa
cosa in quel periodo ma non è finita qui
una delle sottotrame di questa puntata
dove appunto si parla di Reven porn e di
omosessualità e il filmino porno di
Paola Barale la Barale un vero talento
una regina del sesso altro che Pamela
Anderson ed essendo il 2001 quindi
internet non ce l'ha praticamente
nessuno due dei protagonisti devono
andarlo a recuperare comprando una
videocassetta da due loschi individui ma
purtroppo questo Santo Graal dei filmini
porno di Paola Barale è stato comprato
da qualcuno che gli ha bruciati sul
tempo sai chi Paola Barale stessa
il Cameo di Paola Barale e lei che
recupera la videocassetta del filmino
porno di se stessa erano così avanti
questa serie che si sono proprio
schiantati contro un muro parte
e potrei andare avanti per ore dicendovi
che sono scoppiato a ridere quando tra
una puntata e l'altra c'erano gli stessi
attori della serie che facevano la
pubblicità alla coloreria italiana
perché canotta gialla più colorante
azzurro uguale che la nostra verde e
come se a metà di una puntata di mare
fuori ci fosse malpas che dicesse Ciao
sono Nicolas e questo è il Mocio Vileda
e poi è arrivato dopo una settimana
l'ultima puntata devo dirvi l'esperienza
forse
essendomi abituato dopo una decina di
puntate al ritmo al fatto che le storie
lei siano un pochino noiose ma non è
così male anzi il finale quando è finito
un pony è dispiaciuto sai che sai
finisce una serie ci hai quel buco allo
stomaco che dici o no Adesso esco dalle
loro vite loro escono dalla mia non dico
di essere arrivato a quel livello lì di
How I Met Your Mother mah Dai è stato
carino sarebbe potuto essere molto
peggio ma non regge il confronto con
nessun'altra cosa dottor oceano
purtroppo ed è per questo che si sono
fermati ad una singola stagione quindi
vi ringrazio e anche voi adesso potrete
avere un aneddoto da raccontare ai
vostri amici sul Friends italiano
[Musica]
fa schifo
grupponi di amici che prepara un viaggio
per il Guatemala ma vi viene nostalgia
di casa e volete guardare un episodio
anzi l'unico episodio di timvision di
via Zanardi 33 Ma non potete o la
soluzione che fa per voi cambiate serie
oppure nordvpn
ormai lo sapete con Nord VPN potete
connettervi ad un IP diverso da quello
del vostro paese Per usufruire dei
servizi di quel paese ma serve anche a
proteggere la vostra connessione quando
vi connettete alle reti pubbliche per
esempio e se attivate la Tret Protection
avrete un ulteriore difesa contro
malware e pop up invasivi e Per
usufruire delle offerte il codice sconto
Yotobi è sempre in descrizione
[Musica]